good afternoon council please be seated
i'd like to invite
reverend jim ed to say prayers
thank you
i appreciate that uh some or many of you
uh may have had a weekend focused on
william shakespeare
his life his writings and plays and
therefore i thought i'd
prayers
so first of all from as you like it
these well-known words all the world's a
stage
and all the men and women merely players
they have their exits and their
entrances
and one man in his time plays many parts
so lord jesus as we come to the business
of this meeting today we reflect on life
stage
and where you have placed us in it
we particularly lift the commitment and
responsibility of the office which we
hold
as we serve and represent our local
communities here today
in a quiet time of quiet we think about
the agenda items
policies and those aspects of council
life
and work that we are most passionate
about
and from the merchant of venice
we do pray for mercy
and that same prayer
doth teach us
all to render the deeds of mercy
lord we do pray for your mercy to be
upon humanity
whose nature so easily seems to turn to
aggression at our last council council
meeting we prayed against
and indeed it was
we continue to lift you the people of
ukraine
those who have remained and those who
have fled
we lift you refugees
who are coming into our communities
may they be welcomed with open arms
we pray for all who hold up
peace for peace in our world and our
nation
locally we lift you those involved in
policing our streets and upholding the
law
we also give thanks for those providing
healing across our communities those
involved in medical care
the hospices the charities supporting
those in crisis
and those furthering environmental work
as the line from the merchant of venice
states help us to also be merciful
in a time of quiet we think of a
situation we are involved in
in which we could be more merciful
or there is a need for mercy
and william shakespeare's opening line
in his last will and statement
i commend my soul into the hands of god
my creator
believing through the merits of jesus
christ my savior
to be made a partaker of everlasting
life
lord jesus with easter behind us the
church celebrates people's experience of
the risen jesus
found in the bible
those who walked and talked with him
those who realized all was not lost
those who realize that despite the mess
and hurt in the world
jesus
offers something unworldly
resurrection
renewal forgiveness and hope
jesus help us to be people of hope to
those we meet
help us to be people of renewal and
change for the better for those we
our local communities
and our draw our prayers together in the
words of the lord's prayer as
shakespeare would have heard it
our father which art in heaven
hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done in
earth as it is in heaven
give us this day our daily bread and
forgive us our debts
as we forgive our debtors
and lead us not into temptation
but deliver us from evil
amen thank you
thank you
um
item one please my i invite the head of
paid service to report the list of
apologies for absence
thank you chairman apology has been
received from councillors poetic and
counselor harvey and councillor kendall
thank you
thank you
uh i now would like to invite members to
make their declarations of interest to
the meeting
do you have any uh councillor rock
thank you chairman um
uh in respect to item 12
number two
uh since 2010 i've been generating
electricity with a photovoltaic system
and i'm in receipt of a government
feeding tariff in common with thousands
of members of the public
uh chairman i've already spoken to
councillor rock about this issue and
i've advised him that i would issue a
dispensation to him
and to any others in the room who have a
similar interest
thank you councillor junaid
yes i'm a director for a
local community
energy company
it's a not company a charity
which is
raises not it's not for profit and it
raises money for local charities
and i don't receive uh any
finance as a result of that but i still
would be
feel more comfortable if i did not take
part in the uh discussion i also have
solar panels and received feeding tariff
as well
thank you councillor parry
thank you chairman i just like to advise
members i also have solar panel panels
and
and have had them for 15 16 years and
receive the feeding tariff on a
quarterly basis
thank you
um item number three sorry phil uh
councillor fragili
thank you councillor kessel
council dixon council or [ __ ]
lovely good c actually how many
councillors have solar panels well done
um so item three uh now seek a proposal
and second to please for the minutes of
the meeting held on 21st of february so
proposer councillor mills secondary
council dixon
thank you
is that all agreed
thank you
so earlier today i received a petition
from councillor junaid um 475 signatures
from the people of ulster communities on
behalf of residents and it's about
essentially how the district council can
help to restore the three tons pub back
to
um its former self after its fire so
thank you council june edifor for
delivering that to me
um
so you will have noticed we've got a
special guest with us uh here today
counselor kevin taylor the mayor of
stratford on avon town council
so over the last 12 months i've been
i've spent a lot of time with the mayor
attending all sorts of events
from wondering the woods of warwickshire
doing search and rescue drills
to riding the carousel at the mop
so as my time as chairman is coming to
an end i just wanted to record my thanks
to the mayor for his services to the
town and for his support in my role as
chairman so i'd just like to propose a
vote of thanks to the mayor so please
may seek a second
council jefferson so thank you so much
and i'd just like to
introduce uh mayor taylor to say some
words
thank you very much chair um it's and
thank you very much for the invitation
here today uh obviously
it has been a great honor to fulfill
this role um but there are lots of thank
yous
to go around to all of the people who've
supported me through the year to allow
me to fulfill it in the manner that i
wanted to
i'd like to say a big thank you to ed as
well because obviously we we have
attended many events together and
supported and promoted the town at
numerous events uh very successfully
but i think the main thing that we
should all be very very proud of is the
return we see
to almost the normality of what we
previously saw here in
stratford-upon-avon
we look at our town now and we see
new businesses arriving
a lot
30-plus new businesses arrived here in
our town centre
since the end of the pandemic
me to actually fulfill this role
one that will be very difficult to
follow after this i can assure you so
i'd just like to say thank you very very
very much for being given the honor to
come here and speak today and more more
more than anything
for being allowed to be the mayor of
stratford-upon-avon thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you
so recently i also held my uh charity
ball and bingo so we raised a great
amount of money
for life space in the heart of england
forest so thank you to those who are
able to come along and support that
um and recently this weekend um it was a
very very busy one celebrating life with
william shakespeare uh i would like to
congratulate councillor chris kessel on
his role of helping dame judy dench and
cirque and ifrana to herd those sheep it
was quite quite a sight
and then just to
end my announcement so i just like
wanted to wish council tony dixon all
the best for his walk from london to
stratford
which starts this week raising money for
the shakespeare's hospice so good luck
to you
um i'd now like to call upon councillor
rock to address the meeting
thank you chairman um
i thank the chairman
and the leadership of the council for
the opportunity to speak about a bit of
good news
the same news because it's not actually
that new
but this is the first chance
since the release of nazarene zazari
radcliff on 6th march
councillors will remember the discussion
we have had at earlier council meetings
about this case
and alex loftus and her family
alex lives in my ward and is nazaneen's
cousin
i would like to pass on her thanks and
that of the family for all the well
wishes received during the incarceration
and since nazanin's release
the family have pursued a delicate
balance between
the desire for public pressure and of
caution
in fact when i was re-elected in 2019
i thought about what could be
contributed locally but david buckland
was cautious
he and i were both concerned about the
possibility of making things worse
not that i imagine
that the iranian revolutionary guard
watched stratford district council
webcasts on a regular basis
nor that we could make things much worse
than inviting iranian diplomats to
london to discuss the tank debt and then
locking them up overnight and sending
them back the next day
however
as time went on though the apparent
inaction of the foreign office increased
my frustration and keeping the nazaneen
case in the public eye seemed to be the
thing to do
there was support across this council
chamber as the milestone of 2000 days
was passed in october last year with
councillors wearing the little
lilac flower badges that alex gave us
which supplanted an earlier idea that
you'll be pleased to know of wearing
free nazaneen t-shirts
for councillors to wear which i did
explore but we kicked into touch
in the end nazaneen was
detained for
2174 days
all through that period the extended
family had sunday evening conference
calls which must have dominated the
thinking of the whole family
who for most of that time actually knew
little of what was going on in tehran
while nationally the supreme efforts of
richard radcliffe
parliamentarians and especially the
radcliffs london mp tulip siddiqui were
well known there were other local
attempts at publicity
schools in the southam area and the
local amnesty and un groups did what
they could
my colleague richard dixon the runner-up
in the kennels and southern seat
highlighted the issue in his speech
after the general election count in
december 2019.
there are others wrongfully detained
aboard although yesterday we heard that
luke simmons is being released from
yemen
the foreign office must redouble their
efforts in the case of london board
wildlife conservationist morag tabas
who continues to be detained in iran
whatever the faults of the british
government we should remember others who
continue to be unjustly detained in iran
as they operate a cruel and bizarre form
of statecraft that should be roundly
condemned
nevertheless the workings of our foreign
office do need examination and i'm
pleased that the foreign affairs
committees look at this
like some other case work that we have
one never knows
how much good one has done
but it has been an unusual piece of case
work over the three years
i have
rather broken the rule of getting
emotionally involved or not getting
emotionally involved
but tracking the flight on the way at
home
after the family told me that she's def
she was definitely on it
after a couple of hours of uncertainty
was a great lift
so thank you for everyone for your
encouragement
now then
what should i do with the three nazanin
posters
thank you everybody
thank you councillor rock um please
mayor now invite councillor jefferson
the leader of the council to
make his announcements
thank you chair
i think the main announcement i want to
make is all the work that is actually
being done
to
try to bring the merger to an end that
of course will require a formal vote by
council which will be done in may thank
you chair
thank you and please now i invite um
david brookman to make any announcements
thank you chairman um
it's actually in relation to the point
that the leader just made so if i could
just put a bit more meat on the bones
about when we are anticipating having
meetings in the near future in relation
to
the recommendation from the two leaders
at warrick and stratford to end the the
merger process um we are in well no we
will be having a special meeting of
council
on
the 11th of may following the agm at the
rise of the agm ahead of that in the
morning at nine o'clock we are expecting
to have a special meeting of the cabinet
to consider a report which would then be
recommended to the council in the aft uh
later that morning
dialogue's gone on this morning early
this afternoon with the chair of the
ovue and scrutiny committee we are
expecting a meeting of the ovu and
scrutiny committee to look at
those issues on the 10th of may i
haven't got a time set for that just at
the moment but we hope to notify you of
that in the near future and ahead of
that
we are expecting papers to be published
on the 3rd of may for those special
meetings
and we are looking at a date possibly
the 5th of may
for an all counsellor briefing online to
at least give you the opportunity to ask
questions you might have ahead of the
council debate
so
that was the sum of my um announcements
this afternoon thank you
thank you
item number five public participation so
we've received one uh question which is
on your yellow pieces of paper
uh mr norton is not
able to come to council today but
essentially
the question was about um
excessive speeding with noisy engines in
his local area and uh
we will
reply to mr norton with any further
information
that we have
so item number six uh minute 616 the
notice of motion competitors bids and
grants please may i invite councillor
jefferson as leader of the council to
introduce this report
thank you chair uh this was a notice of
motion
uh
and there was a response that went to
cabinet on the seventh of march
uh the notice of motion
um
stated basically
projects
the reality actually is if one looked at
the paper that went to cabinet
there were countless examples of where
we have been successful in achieving
grants
uh it ranges from one and a half million
from the getting building fund
to helping the delivery of the stratford
riverside project through a marginal
viability for the housing from the
housing infrastructure fund
that was 13.4 million
in
2020
and that was to help deliver
long-lasting airfield phase one
there was 61 000 from the department of
transport for the e-cargo bike grant
and the kind of list goes on
so the reality actually is i can do no
more than actually quote from the
conclusion of the paper
it's clear that the council has been
effective over an extended period in
securing funds
from various funding rounds and various
sources as a result of that
cabinet decided to oppose
the motion
thank you
thank you i now see a second uh
after that proposal is there a second
councillor jennings thank you are there
any other members who would like to
speak on that council junaid
yes i'd like to um make a note about
some of those um
successful bids
an awful lot of them were not done
directly by the council it was they were
done by others on behalf of or in
partnership with the council and one or
two of them at least one of them was
actually quite considerably old it was
not a recent one
so i i think i think that some of the um
part of the answer was a little bit
disingenuous
are there any other councils would like
to speak councillor rock
thank you chairman um i was looking
through the papers of the cabinet um
and the
the motion suggested
a mechanism of making bids more
effective
the options available to the cabinet
was to choose between
deciding whether the council was
effective in its bidding
or whether it was not effective
now
it seems to me this is a distortion of
what was
put in the
in the
the term we're either ineffective or
effective
is it is perhaps
suggesting a misleading choice
i'm not i'm sure nothing i'm going to
say is
going to change what we're about to do
but um i just think there's a learning
point there as to how we consider these
things because there is a continuum
rather than a two-state test for these
things thank you chairman
thank you survivor proposer
and a second are we all in agreement
thank you so item number seven minute
688 the local development scheme
uh please may i invite councillor
pemberton as deputy leader of the
council to introduce his reports
thank you chair
members will be aware that
we are required
to prepare and keep up to date a
timetable
known as the local development scheme
as part of the
preparation and ongoing management of
our local plan policies and documents
um at the cabinet's meeting on the 11th
of april
the revised local development scheme and
its timetable were considered
local planned documents outlined in the
agenda report be approved and that the
stratfor don aven district local
development scheme be revised
accordingly
and that the revised local development
scheme be brought into effect
in accordance with section 15 bracket 7
closed bracket of the planning and cost
compulsory purchase act 2004. bracket
has amended closed bracket members of
council i seek your support for this
thank you
thank you please have a second
uh councillor fielding thank you
are there any other members who'd like
to speak on this
no are we all in agreement
for that
thank you
uh item eight minute 689 the notice of
motion on tree planting uh please may i
invite councillor shenson as portfolio
holder for climate change to introduce
this report
thank you chair
hopefully everyone can hear me um
the motion was put forward by the lib
dems in december 2021
to full council obviously
and whilst any counsellor
can bring motions forward
and suggestions
in my opinion there shouldn't be an
expense of considering the cost benefit
ratio of those suggestions or
of the environment
the lib dems
have chosen to bring this it could have
chosen to abort this
particular motion to the climate change
panel
a panel on which the leader
sits plus counsellor manuela paired
together they would have been given time
and no doubt in my mind we could have
debated it and in the forum that was
specifically set up for this
they know that by bringing it through
full council they'll get airtime
at this meeting at the previous meeting
and media coverage
and effectively in my opinion it's
counter this is counter to climate
change agenda and what the panel
original panel was set up for
the
the very fact that this is printed on
paper
on more than one occasion that seems to
me to be counter again to what we were
talking about on trees
so
whilst i'm happy to support sending a
letter to the secretary of state
i can't recommend the rest of this and
i'll explain why
the subsequent sections in the uh in the
motion set out
that uh
set out sorry that
we were they wanted to double the tree
coverage
within stratford
something like 30 square miles
30 square miles of trees
8 000 hectares
that's the equivalent
of
an area bigger than the size of the city
of wolverhampton
it's over fifty percent bigger than the
size of loch ness
for the football fans the monks do
it's roughly
just over somewhere around about ten and
a half thousand times the size of your
average football pitch
or so put it really simply the
equivalent of one mile wide stretching
all the way from here to birmingham
so the motion itself is ill thought out
in my thought in my opinion
the size and cost of around 350 to 400
million that's been estimated that this
would cost i can just imagine councillor
harvey being totally apoplectic about
this
and and
and uh
and
mr buckland um actually querying how we
were going to afford this um and the the
minimum revenue provision that we would
have to make for this
so
it would have been the equivalent of of
many years of our our actual revenue
to add to so in short
i i really think that we could have we
could have uh as a
cancer junior and i've spoken about we
could this motion could have been put in
a better format as it stands
the these you've got the the response
there for that david barber and myself
have put together
as it stands this this motion
is ill thought out
it's ill it's not being thought through
in terms of cost what it would mean to
our productive land across stratford it
would run through suede
now i know that council junior is likely
uh as she she did at the uh
cabinet meeting
that it was the spirit
of of the motion that we should have
been thinking about
except that nobody defined what that
spirit actually meant
here yeah there we go all we can do is
deal with the motion as it's presented
to us and the motion
should be rejected as being unworkable
we have
um a tree planting
paper coming forward proposal which
again
councillor junaid is well aware of and
council pair together
that this is coming forward
which is a far more sensible and
pragmatic approach to this
so in short i i object to this i do not
recommend it and
and the the cabinet do not recommend
this xsav4
happy to write to the secretary of state
thank you council shenzhen seeking a
second from that proposal
please
councillor jennings uh some members
indicated like to speak uh before i came
around so counselor fielding please
thank you chair
having been involved in about 5 000
acres of woodland
in my youth
it is not an easy job to plant trees
and also the fact is that it uses an
awful lot of agricultural land
we haven't got a lot of poor quality
land in this part of the world it's all
good arable land
also with the current
problems associated in eastern europe
where we will have a shortage of grain
production for a number of years we do
need to allow
or prevent
planting on large scale
and i and i basically
eject the emotion and i think it should
be dismissed
thank you council wally hoggins
thank you um as ever i always bring this
down to the residence of
stratford-upon-avon really and we have
to give credit here because the
residents of stratford-on-haven are
currently um from all the parish council
meetings that i've been to the queens do
believe she's asked for trees to be
planted i would say that the majority of
parish councils are facilitating this
and donating trees that is a thing to
every household within their parish that
is a significant contribution to this we
we always get oh we must do this
the grandiose sort of statements about
we must plant
x number of
seven thousand hectares of trees within
the district our residents are doing
their best to tackle climate emotion
climate emergency they're wanting to do
this they are engaging in it but again
we have to think carefully trees can't
be planted at the moment the next window
of opportunity for this is going to be
the autumn and it might be useful if
actually we wrote to the parish camp
we also need to thank residents for
those that haven't um chopped trees down
within their gardens that have kept and
nurtured them as well because that's the
other issue so i'd just like to say
let's give the residents of stratford
some credit for the work that they're
already doing in in order to offset this
thank you
thank you council councillor
um yes thank you councillor shenson
keeps referring to a report on an answer
uh i've got nothing on my papers and
neither have my colleagues either side
i've not seen any response at all
to this motion
has anyone else has anyone else got it
in front of them
no
no the the response that we were meant
to have it says here report to follow
we've got no report
no response nothing
chairman if if i may
they should be on everybody's desk
a copy of
the um
report to the council
from cabinet on the 11th of april um
to to to be okay apologies for that
council that should have been on the
produce
in in
in short the the recommendation to
counsel from the cabinet was that the
next promotion be rejected save the
proposal that the chief executive writes
the secretary of state to request more
funding to enable the council to
increase tree cover of course this is in
response to the as councillor shenzhen
explained um then notice a motion that
was presented to council on the 13th of
december so again once more apologies
it's not on your desk um chairman if you
wanted just a break for two minutes to
enable us to circulate copies and for
people to see that before yes with the
votes
so i was rep referring to what counselor
shenson said thank you councillor so um
we will move on to the next question and
whilst that next question is being asked
we will ask further papers to the uh
distributors though councillor junaid
can i um refer to the
climate change committee's sixth report
in which it refers to the government's
commitments the government's own
commitment is to scale up our
forestation rates to 30 000 hectares a
year by 2025 and with a commitment to
rising to 50 000 hectares per year
annually by 2035 that's the government
the current government's own commitment
this would cover uh increased woodland
cover from 13 of uk land area to around
20 18 by 2050 with a mix of tree types
that focus on broad leaves that again is
the government's own commitment
the motion did not say that anything
about the district council finding its
own land the land it did not say
anything about the district council
providing any cost what it did say was
to encourage and enable and support uh
organizations in the in the district to
um to make sure that and the district
council has a lot of
ways in which you can do that not least
through the local plan for example
it works with a lot of people when i
look through the climate change
committee report it also looks at the
integration of trees on farmland in
depth it looks at exactly how that can
be done it
looks in depth at the length of
increasing hedgerows
with trees in them with better woodland
and hedge management it goes on as part
of that report to do an assessment of
the cost and benefits of it both the
cost to the nation as a whole and to
parts of the nation but also the
benefits to the nation of providing more
woodland and more trees not only to
climate change does this the report and
this is the report that went to
government
uh but also the the fact that
those trees can be used for example for
harvesting biomass from from trees for
for energy as an energy crop maintenance
of heat lands ongoing costs for zero
carbon fuels and farming practices it
went through the whole
cost
of it and then it looked at the the
benefits
on the wider social and environmental
impacts it is said that the social
benefits of some taking some of m much
more uh action on tree planting would
amount to 0.1 billion per year benefit
to the economy economy by 2035 rising to
0.6 billion per year by 2050 and that
was their advice to the government that
they should do that should carry on
in effect almost doubling the amount of
trees uh in the in the in the country in
across the um across the area and
they're not just saying put it in one
big block that's not the case at all it
was using the ways in which the woodland
trust and the warwickshire wildlife
trust and various other organizations
are already doing heart of england is
already doing which is to expand areas
around areas that they already hold uh
warrior wildlife trust is doing this in
particular they are making sure that
they take low quality land and then
increasing and improving their
biodiversity
and for example what the climate change
committee is also saying is that there
should be um
you know they've looked at the benefits
from increased use of woodland 74
physical health benefits from exercising
in natural environments 14
air filtration for improved air air
quality from increased natural uh
vegetation and also flood risk and
management alleviation from woodland
creation in the upper catchments of
areas so it was not talking about a
block or a you know a of district
council lands at all it was to enable
and certainly in ulster the upland the
flood management catchment areas of um
coming down to ulster they've already
been talking with the environment agency
about planting trees in that catchment
area in order to prevent some of the
colossal damage that affects a town like
ulster when it does flood and there are
other towns in a similar way so you know
we're not we want
the response to this i just cannot
believe that the response was in this
way it was
you know we could have put it in a
shorter way maybe but actually um
when you look at it on i think it they
were it certainly did not say
that the district council had to produce
the land it certainly did not say that
this district council could provide the
cost
this district council has the ability to
support enable and make sure that things
happen
and i think it should be taken in this
that spirit and i would benefit i would
appreciate if people would take it in
that spirit thank you thank you
counselor junaid councillor kessel
thank you mr chairman um
i'm sure we'd all
uh
uh are keen on saying trees
uh but i would just like to point out
that um
stratford as a district
has
more
hectorage of woodland
than the
four other districts within warwickshire
um we got 7100 hectares compared to six
thousand four hundred hectares for the
four other authorities combined
if you then go on and look at our
neighboring authorities from south
africa stafford tamworth west
oxfordshire cherwell south north hans
bromsgrove
the only authority
with a higher amount of trees
is cotsworld
uh which is along the cotswold
escarpment
so
if you take that total number of
16 some authorities we are the second
highest trade authority that doesn't
mean we need to sit on our laurels but
we do need to ensure
um that when we sacrifice land for trees
that we look at where the balance
between agriculture
and
and tree coverage because as council
fielding said earlier on
without agricultural land we don't get
food and at the current moment we have a
very very significant issue about food
production uh as a result of activities
um in eastern europe
and therefore the most important thing
for people to have is food and to lose
another 7 000 hectares of land in in
stratfor district would severely impact
on this ability
uh to produce food for the residents of
the uk
thank you uh mr buckland
chairman thank you i just wanted to
clarify
um
an item that's on the agenda so we're
debating item eight at the moment and on
item eight it does say report to follow
that is the single sheet of paper that
you do have on your desks which is
headed up item eight in the top right
hand corner so that that is a formal
report to council following the meeting
the cabinet on on the 11th of uh april i
just wanted to make that point chairman
thank you thank you for the paper thank
you councillor bradley
thank you
i just like to say i'm a little bit
confused because i understood that the
county actually told me
in the various committees i'm on that
the county does have a deficit
in tree coverage and in wildflower
meadows and they are actually working to
find partners and areas in which
both these deficits can be can be
addressed
i think it's a duty of any council to
look for partnerships to work seriously
to plant as many wood meadows wildfires
and trees as possible and that means a
collaborative collaboration between
counties
towns parishes
community groups forest of hearts
you know stratfor goes wild i mean there
are so many local groups wanting to have
uh leadership so they can actually
identify how to plant trees safely and
properly
it's not an easy thing to plant a tree
and we're not talking about planting
millions of trees in one year it's a
journey it's a long journey and it's a
journey that we've got to start now for
our grandchildren's sake
and i think
raising the issue of tree planting
looking for those partners identifying
even where one tree can go
is the right way way to go every journey
starts with one footstep
planting this number of trees starts
with planting and saving one tree
thank you councillor jefferson
thank you chad
i would just like to pick up the point
the council fragile raised about a long
journey
when we had the debated cabinet
i raised the issue about food supply
i raised the issue about climate change
there's absolutely no doubt about it the
climate change may well inhibit food
supply
uh increasing temperatures
uh already uh in the russian harvest
last year reduced yields 30
climate change is going to bring more
floods and more droughts
it's going to bring sea level rise
forecast at at least a meter this year
that is going to actually take away a
lot of land that could grow food
there's the other issue about retreating
glaciers
retreating snow lines
the reality is that will actually
inhibit
irrigation of land for agriculture
reducing
production of food
not only that at the moment
we are mining out a number of aquifers
across the world
which actually again
will reduce food production
there is no doubt at all to me
that there will become a tension
in terms of food production and food
supply
and we need to be very careful
before we commit land use to other
things
and i think the opportunity cost of
growing trees
does need to be matched against food
production
because i don't think there's much doubt
people would actually want food
so i think there's got to be a very
careful balance in this
and at the moment and i made this
pointed cabinet
i saw a notice of motion
that was actually simplistic and
one-dimensional
actually i stand by that
and i think we've got to get a lot more
sophisticated in our thinking before we
put forward proposals that may well have
seriously unintended consequences
thank you councillor adam
thank you very much uh chairman um i
noticed that um councillor shenton
labored over the metrics of how to
define the area that were being given to
us in terms of coverage but these
weren't actually a proportion of the
district which is a very large um rural
district and so that you know just
saying an area doesn't really give us
much of an idea uh on its own uh i'd
also point out that this isn't all
farmland and that we clearly have no
problem in finding space for for housing
on our across the district we need to be
able to
have a diverse um use of land of course
we need to put houses up but we also
need to consider where we are going to
put trees uh and in terms of trees i
think it's fair to say that my ward
along with my neighbors has seen a fair
few cut down in the name of hs2 that
didn't need to be
um not
and on top of that they then planted a
bunch and didn't bother watering them so
they all had to come up as well um
frankly that is a fast to see that type
of thing and then us have to have this
type of debate which um you know brings
down the idea uh and as for the waste of
uh paper and officers time i'm sure
we'll find time for that in future
debates thank you very much thank you
councillor pertiguella
yeah just to um
come back from what council or adam says
um we do have a good agricultural launch
grade two great tree
and and some of this agricultural land
is actually been sacrificed to build
houses i had a very good agricultural
land in my world where houses have been
um
uh allowed by the council so is the
cabinet saying that is okay to sacrifice
agricultural land and food production
for housing developments and offer tree
planting
thank you councillor rock
thank you chairman
um well council adam pinched a couple of
things that i was going to say because
uh
i too am plagued by hs2
and as was pointed out there is a plan
to plant some trees and uh councillor
shenton
mentioned this strip that's going to go
all the way to birmingham
and some of that is hs2
when that when they've not stopped
cutting down trees and planting them and
not watering them if they get it to work
there will be a strip of trees
that would be planted before 2045 which
will probably go all the way to
birmingham who knows but um
they'll be well on the way to doing some
of that so there'll be a considerable
chunk taken out of this target now
council shenton mentioned he was
interested in the words
the words that were written down he said
rather than the emotion
and
counselor shen is a very perceptive man
i do know but he didn't seem to be
quoting what's written down here
beca
i'm looking at
page 20 of the cabinet report if you
read the top of it he's probably got it
in front of me i'm sure but it's all
about targets as councillor june said it
doesn't say
david buckland get get your money out
and pay for this straight away or it
doesn't say pay for it in the next 200
years it says
seek funding from other places so i i
think
you know that
it's
it's clear we want to look at the word
so i think he's right in that respect
but i i commend him to to take his own
words at face value
and and i i think uh the leader was
right he said there is a balance to to
be struck
that balance includes us all but
participating in a really useful
discussion about the best way
for climate change and what we can do
for the district
now i'm sure councillor shinton has been
straight on
to the monitoring officer to debate the
constitution
and say this is not a proper way of
doing it we mustn't be able to bring
uh things to debate
we shouldn't be able to put motions
forward because there should be some
better way of doing it to take it some
other route opposition shouldn't be able
to bring these things forward
councillor shenzhen if you think that's
the right way of doing it to stifle
democracy
please
get onto the monitoring officer and stop
us being able to do that i don't agree
with you that's what it says in the
constitution if we want to put motions
forward we'll carry on to do that and
we'll bring these forward for a useful
debate to explore the balance that the
leader says so that's what we're here
for that's what we should be discussing
let's hear everybody's views about this
have a useful discussion about it
i rest my case thank you council rock
councillor councillor crump
thank you mr chairman
um yeah i just come through my ward as
well oh
and it's given me loads of grief and
before hs2 i didn't have these gray
hairs but now i've got quite a few
mistaken for cancer kettle on some
occasions
um
but but seriously um
yeah i think we need to be refined what
we're doing we've already touched on
various issues you know
sea levels rising the amount of flooding
etc and lots of land can be used for
natural flood protection
and this natural flood protection will
be very difficult
we can't plant trees on them and two
nobody in the planning committee would
ever deem to plant any um plant any
trees build any house in areas subject
to flooding will we not at all mr
chairman
um
but but seriously i think we do need to
look up this properly planting trees is
fine but again hs2 when i covered a a
previous candy council award um planted
trees in part of an area and then they
didn't look after them about a third of
them died
so let's like look at this properly
let's do it with sensible head-on
perhaps even a root and branch exercise
just to make sure we're doing it
properly
and yeah
i think yeah it's it's it's from a game
show it's good but not quite right um
can you remember that one catchphrase
yeah good but not quite right so i'm
doing me roy walker here so but
seriously i think that's that's the bit
proper let's do it you know joined up
thinking let's work with the county see
what they're doing it's like cancer
fragility says you know
they've got different evidence or
they've got evidence so let's do it
properly joined up thinking and get
other people involved as well to use
some of their money so
i certainly um
endorse people's desire to have these
trees because the the benefits
especially to wood
wildlife etc but yeah let's do it
properly thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
thank you chair um would it be possible
to put down an emergency motion to get
to net zero puns by 2030 please
um i find myself having to try to come
to the rescue of councillor shenton
um the the notion of
the involvement of the climate change
panel
was something that i raised at the
cabinet and asked a question of the
monitoring officer
and that was around the question of
climate related motions specifically and
whether a more effective route to help
support council would be for
uh the opportunity to refer such motions
to the climate change panel if they
didn't go through the climate change
panel in the first instance
so that
the group of members and the officers
that support them could
give some input to support council
it's not for us as an administration nor
would we seek in any way shape or form
to try and stifle debate um
it's
it as an opposition it's not your job to
give the administration an easy ride and
nor should you um but just to clarify
that the the notion of
um
and as i understand as i recall the the
monetary officer said that without
actually a change to the constitution we
couldn't have an additional sort of
option from you know when emotions put
down to refer it through to the climate
change panel in the way that you would
refer it to through to or not to
officers so really just to clarify that
there wasn't the notion of saying you
you would not be able to bring motions
forward but that one of the options
could be that the climate change panel
itself with the expertise that supports
it would be a useful mechanism to
prevent to bring some clarity to a
further discussion by council as it
happens the the monitoring officer
didn't feel that we could potentially do
that but from my perspective
yeah just keep bringing challenging
things to us and we'll debate them as we
should
thank you
thank you councillor fleming
thank you chairman um
i think sometimes
for
regular people these huge schemes of so
many hundred
hectares and whatever else it's hard to
visualize and hard to see how it can
work
the thing is um going back to what
council holly hoggins was saying about
parish councils we're on part of bidford
on abram it's a very active parish
council in actual fact i've started a
tree audit with the paris council and
with uh private enterprise um so that we
can find out what we've what we've
actually been doing now i did put to the
climate change panel that we should do
this you know have a tree audi
throughout the various parishes and
unfortunately it was kind of knocked
down by a director who said that some of
our schemes are small and insignificant
i did pull him up bloody hard on that um
but having said all of that what we have
to do is
start with start with systems that we
can understand the size of um we have a
thing in our parish where any public
open space that can't be used for
recreation sport or whatever is going to
be planted with trees especially in the
jubilee year so from that perspective i
think
most of the parishes around here should
have some public open space that they
can't
play games on play sports on or use for
recreational or other activities and get
some trees in there and once we start
with that then some of these numbers
will suddenly start to stack up and
become a useful number for us all to be
working on but trying to talk about so
many hundred hectares at a time average
people can't understand what that's all
about so from that perspective start
with the ground
using one of his puns now start with the
ground up and uh and let's uh and let's
move forward with what the parishes are
doing find out what we've actually got
and where we can go from there so that's
all thank you very much thank you uh
council orcok
thank you chair
i know when you like start looking at
the number of trees it would take to
fill wolverhampton or the number of
trees it would take to fill 10 football
pictures it's completely overwhelming to
imagine that many trees
but the pyramids weren't built in a day
they were built one stone at a time
what this motion is asking for
is to look at this as a idea going
forward
it doesn't have to be done in a day
it can be looked onto a long-term vision
but every
role every council who are looking to
build to plant trees
will be doing it one tree at a time
now i understand what the what the
leader said regarding um
if they're going to have to be a choice
between building trees and looking at um
growing food
well
some food things do actually grow on
trees i understand um fruit etc so i
can't see why one is mutually exclusive
to the other
i know my ward of bishop turned with the
there is a community orchard that it
will be built there
with fruit
that the residents there could
can use if they wish
so i don't see that should be a reason
to just
say no absolutely not we have to focus
another way
there's ways to work around this and the
way to start it
is with one tree
one tree in one place and then you move
on to the next
not everything has to be done
immediately
thank you
thank you uh councillor shenton would
you like to
say anything
thank you very much
point of order
point mr chairman
uh councillor shenzhen has already
spoken once chairman hasn't he is it so
i thought the uh proposing that
secondary people are allowed to do that
so the council procedure rules allow the
proposer of the original motion to
have the final say
and is that council attention
thank you
we've had the response from mr grafton
and now i'd like to invite council
shenton to make any final comments but
excuse me
council richards didn't notice you
sorry chairman yeah i wasn't going to
speak on this but obviously i've
listened to what everyone's had to say
um and particularly coming back on
councillor allcock she said this is a a
desire to plant trees it all starts with
one trade at a time that's all very well
and good your the exact wording of the
motion was
set a target to at least at least double
the canopy the tree be coverage within
our local authority area by 2045. that's
a doubling by 2045 that's 22 and a half
years away
if the numbers that we've just heard
from cancer shenzhen are correct and i
believe you said 400 million is required
to
to achieve that that's an average
commitment a commitment an average
commitment per year of 20 million pounds
even on the conservative estimate of 350
million you're looking at a minimum 15
million a year and that's a commitment
you want to make this count for this
council now point of order that's absurd
i think that's absurd
councillor castle junaid you've had your
opportunity and i've got the chair now
to commit the council to that sort that
level of expenditure i think is utterly
absurd what i do agree with is the
desire to plant trees but in its current
form
this motion cannot be supported purely
on a financial basis so i'm not going to
support this i am going to
go along with the recommendation that
has been put forward
there is a desire to plant trees we have
the biodiversity net gain program as
well let's have a better think of how we
can bring this forward rather than
committing this council to that level of
expense now when if i'm honest most of
us aren't going to be sat in this
chamber in 20 years time
thank you thank you councillor o'donnell
uh thank you chair um i would just like
to pick up on points raised by fellow
members but actually we just need to
take a step back in
the idea around wanting to plant more
trees is obviously um something we're
all keen to do but if we take a step
back there's already a huge amount of
work going forward we have the queen's
jubilee canopy going on but i've got
three of my parish councils who want to
build far more if we want to build farm
plant farm more trees not build trees
plant far more trees where they're
looking at their open spaces we have the
biodiversity project in allscott which i
know a number of you came and visited
and i think it is about us looking at
the joint working across our communities
and across our district and not jumping
in with a motion that actually as peter
as councillor richards has pointed out
is completely unaffordable on many
levels so it's simply taking a step back
it's not that we are not in favor of
increasing the true coverage but it's
really looking at how can we have a more
joined up
mature that's a pun for you andy mature
approach to actually getting more trees
in there so i just uh we take the step
back thank you
i'm going to invite the chief executive
to quickly make an announcement chairman
yeah just just fully address the point
of order that council
introduced
it's clear a counselor can only speak
once in relation to emotion however
under uh council procedural 15.8 the
proposal of the motion and this is not a
new rule this has been involved out of
an item has the right to summarize
before put to the vote
sorry
chairman is there a further point of
order
can we clarify there seems to be some
confusion over who is the proposer of
this motion is it counter is it
councilman yes councillor chenton is the
proposer of the recommendation back from
the cabinet to the council thank you for
that clarification you're welcome at the
start of this debate i did seek a
proposal and second uh
fantastic so councillor curtis was that
your question
great thank you any further questions
from counselors who haven't spoken on
this council jennings
my my issue with this is sort of the
ambiguity of the wordings of
wasting officers time and money
um i think it's important that these
emotions are put together with a bit
more thought and refinement
because sometimes it's difficult to see
the wood from the trees in these motions
thank you council chanting would you
like to close the debate please
thank you chair um i have to say i
i have enjoyed the debate um
i'm i'm quite sure that uh councillor
rock is trying to work out
he's made a valiant attempt there to put
to to put words into my mouth by saying
a valiant attempt
but no prize for that that
everyone knows that i actually said at
the cabinet and uh very clearly
it wasn't an attack on democracy at all
it was a
suggestion that it should come through
the climate change panel the very panel
that your representatives
want to keep and attend so nice try
council iraq i appreciate that and a
nice try on the on the um
on
the point of order
it's quite clear
that this this is as i say is an ill
thought out motion
it's very clear it it's that it's in
terms of cost we kind of we couldn't
commit to it in terms of size it's just
beyond most people's comprehension i
understand
that you know people that the the
comment about um well wolverhampton it
means nothing but it gives you some
perspective of what we're talking about
in terms of size
so
whilst uh
as i say i've enjoyed
listening to the debate
i feel still feel very strongly that
this was an ill-thought-out motion and
it was
as i've said in the cabinet meeting and
i wasn't going to necessarily say at
this time but in the cabinet meeting my
feeling is that this was more about
the lib dems
trying to grab the hijack the the very
agenda the climate agenda that we
and i've gone to great lengths to avoid
politicizing
it's more about greenwashing than
anything else
because if you were so concerned about
the climate agenda you might well have
voted for the one two three plus but
instead you chose to abstain
despite your leader at that time
indicating to me that you would vote for
it
so your climate change credentials
no
so as far as i'm concerned the
recommendation should stand and that's
that
should be the the notice should be
refused stay for
um writing to the secretary of state
thank you thank you so my perception is
that members are not in agreement so
please may they those in favor
of of the proposal raise their hands
please
thank you and those against please
and and those abstaining please
i can there was 19 votes for
seven votes against and therefore it is
carried thank you so that is we've three
extensions that is carried so moving on
to item nine
council questions so 11 questions have
been received and these have been
circulated so you're all on a separate
sheet
so all members asking a question will
have the opportunity to ask one
supplementary question
um
question one counselor fielding do you
have a supplementary question
not at the moment i would like to raise
it with
the portfolio holder
as soon as possible thank you and
likewise for question two
i think this goes back to what we've
been discussing
about
building in the countryside
um we have some very
large and some small old agricultural
sites that could easily take some of the
housing that we need and could also lead
to affordable homes as an add-on to
the
development of these farm buildings i
think it's important that this should be
raised and brought forward
thank you councillor pemberton um
thank you councillor fielding um i think
we've
we've agreed to pick up on some of the
issues that you've raised and some other
issues following on from the overview
and scrutiny
meeting on friday morning
and
in terms of anything that comes out of
that discussion that has wider interests
and implications for members uh i'll
arrange to provide an update to members
on on that discussion i know some of
these issues are specific for you
councillor fielding but those that have
wider wider interests i'll i'll update
everyone thank you
thank you uh councillor eden do you have
a supplementary question
uh no not at the moment thanks council
thank you council curtis
yes thank you
um
it would appear from
the reply
that i've had that the original
information prevented presented to ovue
and scrutiny
on which we were asked to make
recommendations was at the very least
incomplete and in my view somewhat
misleading for the committee
we were at that meeting on 3rd of
february 2021 15 months ago
presented with the project that was
shovel ready
with a clear timetable with occupation
by august 2021 eight months ago
overview and scrutiny was certainly not
told that the timetable was quote
developed without the knowledge of the
property's unregistered status with the
land registry
nor that the timetable was largely
dependent on external factors
asking members to make important
decisions without perhaps providing all
the relevant facts
appears to be becoming something of a
habit with this conservative council and
we're only too aware
of the latest consequences of asking
members to make recommendations without
necessarily being fully informed
thank you councillor
number one
it now seems the best estimate of
completion
is january 2024
two and a half years later than the
original timetable prevented to overview
and scrutiny
given a very tight well i have
repeatedly i will come to my question
now
but i think the context is important
chair
i've repeatedly suggested to the chair
of overview and scrutiny that there
should be regular monitoring and review
of sil projects
so in the light of the inadequate
initial report and significant delays
and remaining uncertainties
surrounding this project
will the portfolio holder commit to a
quarterly review
of all sill projects to ensure that they
are kept on track and on budget and if
not we are able to carry out a thorough
review
thank you thank you councillor barker
no
thank you
council adam do you have a supplementary
question
yes thank you
um
sorry uh thank you councillor pemberton
for the answer uh response you gave um
and i'm glad i'm glad to hear that there
are assurances that um do restricts
offer restrictions on development uh in
the district of course i'm aware of that
as a as a member of the planning
committee um
one thing i was wondering though in with
regards to this uh specifically is um
thank you um
as you know in your response um the the
technical evidence is a few years old
now um and i mean reading the climate
change spd it does talk about in this
case say solar panels and things but we
don't have necessarily a strategic view
and i'm slightly concerned that the time
scale for the new local plan is such
that
it might overtake us is there scope that
we can kind of
have a more interim
plan strategy that we could produce
effectively to look into this um also um
i'm not aware that the
if what the um incentives were for local
communities such as paris councils or
such that might want to to look into
this part of the question thanks thanks
council pemberton
uh thank you very much council madam
sorry sorry guys i was just struggling
to to to focus in on that um
if councillor adam are you asking me
will
would we go down a sort of second
interim climate spd um no i think it's
where i'm at with that and principally
because
um
one of the potential uh and it was uh
it's part of a brief discussion i've had
with the uh with john carefort earlier
today
there were some assumptions made around
the delivery of the new local plan
um that now can be potentially revised
because of more recent events
so there may be an opportunity to get to
where we need to get
there was some question of whether
all cycle would impact on that
the commitment i will give to you is
that i'm as i am in as much of a hurry
as you are councillor adam uh to get to
where we need to be uh undoubtedly um as
we look at how the
work of the plan goes forward um
i will be quite rightly required both
through this council and through
overview and scrutiny
to provide updates
to members
i haven't got the answer for you now
but we're all in a hurry so if you would
uh bear with me on that as soon as i've
got more for you but my inclination
firmly is to get to
policies under the new plan rather than
any sort of further um interim measures
thank you so question six council junior
do you have a supplementary question
um yes uh i do um on the answer that has
have been given uh there's actually
several inaccuracies so i'd like to ask
some questions
follow up on those
in the second paragraph about um when
the owners swiftly responded positively
to taking action that paragraph
the actual position was
that i was in touch with the district
council in early november 2021 about the
impact of bad weather uh on this grade
two listed building and further damage
i was advised that formal action to
temporarily renegotiate a roof cover was
possible
negotiations with building control legal
services were undertaken
on november the 19th i was asked did i
agree
to an urgent works notice to be secured
to protect the building over the winter
i gave my permission to that negotiation
and for that formal work formal
urgent works notice to be issued
then i was told it by not in writing but
by the officer concerned
that after they
that agreement for an urgent works
notice had gone in
the officer at the time said they were
looking at examples
i was told that the off that offer had
been overturned
by the cabinet member who said that only
negotiations would be the way forward
but no formal works notice should be
undertaken so i'd like to ask what that
the actual situation was was on that
i was then told in january that
structural engineering's
structural engineers met on site with
our own building controls and was told
that so much damage uh so much water had
entered the building that further damage
had occurred
and that therefore a temporary roof
structure which was the supposed to be
the
i've been
badgering
since then for information the
information they it says in here that
i've been kept fully informed only when
i have fully
badgered the officer constantly have i
been kept informed
i was told that stripping out would
proceed with a temporary crash deck on
april the twentieth
the last one says it's our understanding
that these works commenced last week
no they have not commenced no works have
yet started
i bring to your attention sorry
counselor june admire just interrupts
you here i bring to your attention
you have the opportunity to ask one
supplementary question i know you are
you asked a question is that the
question you'd like to ask counselor
parry to answer
i finish by saying i bring attention to
the petition that has been presented to
the chairman
could you make sure that the at their
portfolio answers not just to me but to
the 475 residents
that responded and signed that petition
thank you councillor parry
thank you chairman
um thank you very much councillor junid
um
for your various responses i thought
it'd be very helpful for everybody to
demonstrate how well the enforcement
team deal with an inquiry
enforcement team have made on this
particular case
any building that suffers a fire
or any
situation which requires formal
enforcement is taken extremely seriously
this is a grade two listed building
both the conservation team
and the enforcement team have been
heavily involved
because it is a grade two listed
building
the owners of the building had to get
obviously their insurance and loss
adjusters involved this has taken the
considerable anyone who
and in my family we have had a situation
where we've had a house fire and i can
assure you it takes a very long time for
insurers and loss adjusters to come to
some agreement
on the costs and how to go about
getting the various advisors involved
i think it's very evident that the
enforcement team have been very much on
this case they have kept the ward member
fully informed and they have taken the
appropriate enforcement action when they
were able to i would like to say they
were very disappointed
to have received the criticism they have
i would be delighted to send all this
information through to those who signed
the petition
we noted the media interaction in the in
the paper unfortunately as everybody
knows once you have
make a formal response
what i will say is i know the
enforcement officer it has had our
highest level enforcement officer take
charge of this particular case
and
i know she has been particularly
detailed and pedantic in responding to
your counselor junior i'm sorry and i
apologize if you feel that you have not
been kept informed but members of
council
30 interventions over a course of 12
months on one case i think actually
shows a great deal of diligence
and all i can say is everything that is
detailed in this report which is noted
on a diary aspect through the
management system as far as i was
concerned was correct and as far as
you advising i advise not to issue a
works notice well i don't think i was in
the same meeting thank you
thank you uh councillor junior do you
have a supplementary question for
question seven please
i would like to
i would like you to come to ulster
and compare the the way the reaction
that happened is this your question
seven please
i would like it the invitation is to
come to ulster and explain that to the
residents
12 months
council barca do you have anything you'd
like to respond to that as that was
counselor junior's question seven
response
thank you
counselor
no because that was the option to do so
per square do you have a supplemental
question for question eight please no
but i look forward to the meeting with
councillor shanton
thank you council shane would you like
to reply
no
thank you question nine councillor
curtis do you have a supplementary
question please
thanks joe yes um i'm surprised and
disappointed by the answer to my
previous question i believe members of
the public would welcome regular
monitoring and reporting of projects
involving public funding but the
portfolio holder clearly doesn't believe
so
but um in response to this specific
question uh thanks for this answer and
following the recent successes in grant
funding which the leader outlined
earlier on in today's meeting
i'm sure and i hope the council will be
successful in whatever bid does go
forward just like to have reassurance
from the leader that whatever scheme is
brought forward in any application the
relevant ward members would be fully
consulted
thank you thank you council jefferson
thank you chair
uh it's
we are beginning to put together this
possible structure a bid
and uh
yes the ward member
will be involved
um however i have to say that one of the
interesting things about putting these
bids together is an awful lot depends on
the criteria and then an awful lot
depends on the way
the bids are evaluated which obviously
is not under our control
thank you uh council alcock do you have
a supplementary question
yes please
ouch yes please chair um
yeah can i just confirm to the portfolio
holder regarding the answer
um
that you won't be writing
the police crime commission has
requested
um if not then i will do it myself on
behalf of the residents
thank you
thank you
any member of the authority uh or the
residents of the authority can speak to
the police and crime commissioner we do
speak to the crime commissioner a lot
we're not responsible uh and neither
policing crime for operational policing
matters
um operational policing matters are of
course the responsibility of the police
but we have had um
there has been concern
uh there has been a very minor rise but
there have been two arrests as you'll be
fully aware in the area um following the
disturbances to which you brought my
attention uh so as far as i'm concerned
if following those disturbances there
have been arrests of people and carrying
out uh those activities and charged and
i believe sentenced
then uh i'd like to congratulate the
police on their effectiveness in
stratford
thank you um council bertha scala i
noticed that council harvey is not here
today so um if you've got a supplemental
question i'd like you to invite that
okay thank you
great so moving on to item 10 uh
questions to the leader so just remind
the police that each member has two
questions
three minutes in total for each please
and only matters that are the
responsibility
of this council so do we have any
questions counselor ian for actually
please
thank you chair um following on from the
comments in my ward with regard to
increasing green bin charges for 2022
and the manner in which it was
introduced
i did a green bin survey of 144 houses
on bambi road on a recent collection day
you may be delighted to know that 24
percent hadn't put their green bins out
and and of those who did put their green
bins out
68 had a 20 22 sticker on them and 32
percent had a 2021 sticker but not a
2022 sticker
which of course
those buildings wasn't collected on that
particular day
i would like to know if this this kind
of experience in my ward is the norm
um and what i would like to know is can
you tell me how many 21 2021 stickers
were issued last year
and how many 2022 stickers have been
issued so far this year
and of those which have been purchased
this year how many were paid by the
online system and how many uh
by personal attendance at elizabeth
house
thank you council jefferson
i can answer part of this but those
questions are so detailed frankly
counselor fragility i think they'll be
better addressed in written form to the
portfolio holder
last year there were 490 000 sorry 49
000. not 490
49 000 uh stickers issued this year to
date 39
000. thank you council portugal
thank you does the leader of the council
agree that the people of the district
have made immense sacrifices
during lockdown especially when
strafford was put into tier four
and does he agree that rule makers
attending parties and social gatherings
when these were forbidden for the rest
of us is an insult to our residents
council jefferson
i think that is a very interesting
question councillor pertagella
i think though that the reality is that
an awful lot of that it will be down to
the final report that will be issued
and
i
i do think however that people who make
the rules should stick by them
thank you councillor rolf
um thank you chair
um
so now um
we know that the merger is no longer on
the table
can i ask about the
joint local plan
and
whether that's in any danger at all
of not going ahead
and if there is any danger
of it not going ahead
um and to quote councillor matt jennings
earlier on we don't want to waste
officers time do we um you've accused us
of wasting officers time with motions
when we are perfectly within our rights
according to democracy of asking these
motions i just want to know
that if there's any doubt at all
that this local plan joint local plan is
not going ahead
i do think it is in
unfair on the staff involved thank you
thank you councillor jefferson
thank you chair
um
i have to say that quite a lot of work
has been going on at the moment to
identify what may well
continue
uh
that
will be
published on the third of may there's a
paper to cabinet
i think it would be better to wait
until that paper is published so
everyone has the opportunity to see
what's in that paper before commenting
thank you councillor cleve
thank you chair um
uh paul jesus senior email just came to
me today so you may not be able to
answer it but hopefully we can get an
answer first does the district council
have a representative
on the fred winter center steering group
um that's part one of the question is
two questions
and do we know why nothing has been done
following the report in march which um
has been updated today from elizabeth
dixon of accessible stratford about the
poor access accessibility at the fred
winter center including toilets lift
signage and cat on the cafe
thank you thank you council
jefferson i am sure we have a
representative on the fred winter center
and uh
as for the detailed question i will need
to find out and get back to you
thank you
councillor junit
can i first of all um thank the whole
all the members of staff that have been
involved in in the merger over the last
couple of years or so
my question is on the impact
to staff of that merger because i'm i'm
pretty sure it must have had a
tremendous impact on the staff of this
authority
i would like to see some sort of review
made and i'm just wondering whether we
could have an overview and scrutiny
review of what exactly went wrong and
also what
uh making sure that we have understood
all the impact on the staff and that we
have we do know exactly um what um the
the you know what
will go forward i need to understand by
the 11th of may
a lot more of the detail about what went
wrong and particularly the impact on the
staff
thank you council jefferson
thank you councillor junior
um
i think it would be well worthwhile
overview and scrutiny taking a good look
at what happened during the merging
process
i remember when we were working jointly
with chairwolf and south northampton
that overview and scrutiny actually did
a review of what happened then
and it was incredibly useful
the one thing i would say is that at the
moment
talking to staff today
they are incredibly happy
that the merger process has come to an
end
thank you councillor pertiguella
does the leader of the council share my
disappointment the warship county
council failed to win funding from the
government's bus transformation program
especially in view of the sustainable
transport infrastructure study
commissioned by both councils for long
marston garden village
thank you councillor jefferson
sorry
per together was another question about
warwickshire county council on
sustainable transport because transport
is a county council issue
yet
affects our residents and we have
been taking part in the sustainable
transport infrastructure study by a
commission for the long-term garden
village
uh to win funding
i don't know the answer to that council
together i'll have to look into it and
get back to you
thank you councillor fielding
thank you chairman i've got two two
questions but uh the first one
is to do with industry in the district
how much gas do the
various manufacturers need to supply the
industries and particularly
central government are trying to cut
down
on fracking and other matters that's the
first one
i have to say a councillor feeling that
the answer to that question is utterly
beyond me i don't know
and i'm not sure how we could find out
but we will endeavor to do so
thank you council fielding your second
question my second question is to do
with the in uh
deforest
work with regards to the environmental
land management scheme how much work is
the district council done with regards
to the requirements that will go before
agriculture to make sure that they are
the um
developments that take place
might be of interest to the authority
with regards to woodlands and other
matters thank you councillor jefferson
i'm not sure that you say thank you for
your question uh question council of
fielding
thank you councillor o'donnell
thank you chair so osu has had quite a
few mentions during this meeting um just
want to quickly
that we need to have brought it to this
format and it's already within our
planning and osc is a cross-party
committee so
you know we we don't need to make
comments about
current leaderships with current merger
deals everybody brought into that deal
cross-party we need to be honest and own
that
um with regards to the mental health and
the well-being of members of staff
during the merger process this as you
will know leader and as you will know mr
buckland was raised at our regular
updates with yourselves we always asked
about
um staff mental health and well-being
what facilities are being made and we
are covering that and we have covered it
and we will continue to to do that in
our update
so we've already we're already on on the
the route to making sure that there has
been a holistic and nurturing approach
for staff during this process and as
you'll know with the regular updates
that you attended for osc we raised
those points with you and you gave us
clear answers as to the format and the
strategies that were being put in place
so i just want to clarify with osc being
mentioned so often
what was raised previously was already
on the radar and the soft mental health
and facilities around how staff have
been adopted during that process was
brought up regularly during our osc
updates with yourselves which you kindly
attended on a regular basis
thank you
council jefferson
thank you councillor donald you're
absolutely right
uh the chief executive and i did attend
uh i think one thing i would say in
general about any process like the
merger
um there is uncertainty there is stress
there is absolutely no way of avoiding
that
we have done everything we can to try
and ensure that the process went
smoothly
at the end of the day he didn't quite
but uh
at the moment like i say talking to a
number of staff today
uh they are happy
relieved and smiling
thank you do we have any further
questions
no
so item 11 uh for information only um
that the plant life motion has been
deferred pending a report from officers
so item 12 motions on notice
um the first one is on ukrainian
refugees please
this motion
i would like to propose the motion and
speak on it when you do you want me now
okay brilliant thank you
and thank you chair we continue to see
the tragic news of the war in ukraine we
hear of horrific crimes of russian
attacks on civilians the destruction of
villages towns and cities we stand in
solidarity with the brave people of
ukraine in their darkest tower and i
know that my fellow councillors will
wish to express their full support too
data at the beginning of april showed
that 4.2 million refugees that fled
ukraine and that an estimated 6.5
million people have been displaced
within the country and as the conflict
continues many more are predicted to
flee
millions of ukrainian refugees have now
fled to europe poland has taken nearly 3
million refugees
romania
769 6116
and countries which are not bordering
ukraine
have been quick and proactive italy for
example has already welcomed more than
100 000 refugees as per 24 of april and
are expecting up to 800 000 to reach the
country as the war goes on
hundreds of thousands of ukrainian
displaced by the war have asked to come
to the uk
and hundreds of thousands of british
people including this district's
residents have signed up for the homes
for ukraine scheme
offering to welcome refugees into their
homes
i want to thank the immense generosity
of our residents including many families
in my world who have in the last two
months donated fundraised and opened
their homes and their hearts
sadly this generosity is not met by the
government
ministers are falling short of what the
government promised
the government has no way for example
like other eu countries have done the
visa requirements and instead are
offering red tape and an incredibly
bureaucratic application which slows the
process down the latest statistics on
the homes for ukraine scheme show that
less than 10 percent of applicants have
had a visa granted
and even when visa are granted
this does not translate into refugees
being able to come here latest
government figures show that 40 000 uk
visa have been issued under the homes
for ukraine scheme and yet just
hundred ukrainians have actually arrived
we hear of delays with these
applications including individual visa
permit on family members delayed or
withdrawn by the amorphous which means
leaving already traumatized families in
limbo
residents who have applied to be hosts
are worried by the delays and feel let
down when their families are still
waiting for visa to be granted while
bombs
fall around them
or the potential hosts have to resort to
pay for the families to stay in hotels
in neighboring countries while they wait
for permission to enter the uk
there is frustration at a scheme
designed almost to discourage people
from applying
these people are fleeing a barbaric war
there is urgency they need to be able to
come here quickly
the home secretary herself had to
apologize for the delays
yet the scheme was launched after the
government was criticized for his
initial slow response
over the weekend the guardian newspaper
reported of families who applied nearly
five weeks ago and are still waiting for
uk visas despite the promise to approve
them within 48 hours
we would like also extra support for our
council officers are doing a fantastic
job welcoming families supporting hosts
and guests so that they can settle and
start a new life in a safe place i hope
that all members can feel they can
support the motion and instruct the
leader to write to the home secretary to
ask
for the rigid entry requirements to be
eased
to do more to enable councils and
charities to be part of an ambitious
ambitious and safe resettlement scheme
and reiterate the readiness of this
council to welcome refugees thank you
thank you please invite
councillor junior to second this motion
i second the motion and reserve my right
to speak after everybody else's
thank you uh so this motion will now be
debated and counselor jefferson has
already indicated he'd like to speak
thank you chair
i am more than happy to write to the
home secretary uh
saying what is in the final paragraph of
this notice of motion
and i would actually like to thank
councillor pertiguella for mentioning
the officers the hard work they've done
on the effectiveness with which they are
handling the refugees locally uh i think
they are doing an absolutely superb job
and
it has actually had
an impact
and an effect on a number of the
officers that have been dealing directly
with the refugees
thank you are there any other counselors
who would like to speak councillor rock
uh thank you chairman um
i think we're all probably going to
support this motion just a couple of
points i'd like to make um
you know i think the feedback uh from
the population in general stratford in
particular is fantastic in in wanting to
support um
ukraine and and the dreadful things that
have gone on there
uh and what i will say is i've got a
farmer in my ward left his farm
loaded up his vehicles
went to ukraine took supplies to ukraine
which is a sort of indication of what
people are prepared to do so it's
absolutely fantastic
what i would
a couple of things that are related to
that is and i don't know about this but
i think we still haven't solved the
problem of the afghan translators and so
on that i've been brought to this
country and i think i do think we've got
a few of those
in our uh our district that we've not
solved that problem and i think it's a
hard
a hard thing to deal with
as this will be
this problem of the visas and all that
sort of thing has got to be resolved but
when they get here we've got that will
give us another problem i'm looking at
council of bar crop trying to do anyway
this is slightly out of sight and the
other thing
which i would bring to your attention
thank you very much
is that um i i've had an issue
in my award of an empty home a home
that's been
empty for 20 years
which personally i think is an affront
when we've got a shortage of homes and i
think we could do that actually having a
look at that strategically i don't know
how many
are empty but it is in a front when
we're looking for accommodation we will
be looking for accommodation for these
sort of people and i think perhaps we
need to have a look at that council of
barker
trying to look at again
um but uh
let's let by all means let's go for that
but i think we do have problems on our
own doorstep that are likely to um
uh come forward if this happens so thank
you very much
thank you councillor adam
thank you chairman um
touched on one of the the things that
council rock raised um it's actually
i've
in reference to the afghan crisis um
i've actually had two two afghan
families move into my ward and the thing
i'd like to say about that is how um
incredibly open-hearted and the
reception has been from particularly the
parish council
and other people in the community
and i know that's that's just a fraction
of the the willingness people have
within our district uh within our
communities to help people in need um so
i'm really you know i welcome this and
i'm really glad that this seeks to
enable us as the local authority to um
to do what what clearly our residents
are calling for so thank you
thank you counselor wally hoggins
see i can stand up i have got legs um my
extended family is is um hoping to take
in six um refugees for um
imminently but i would like to pay
tribute because we've already had the
my relatives already had the visit and
the council were very efficient in
coming out um they're obviously very
obvious that they're doing some very
thorough checking on the properties and
again they need to be commended for do
for doing that and i'm heartened by that
but i would just like to say this we're
not rubber stamping the visas that are
coming through as a country from the
home office and it's important that we
don't just see this as
speeding up the process we need more
people
at the home office surely to make sure
the proper checks and balances
are being done but yes we share we share
the um my family shares the sort of
incredulity of how long this is taking
because the people that are involved are
aged between four years old
right the way up to sort of middle aged
years as well so but it is important
that we acknowledge the rubber stamp
it's not just a rubber stamping exercise
and giving out the visas that checks and
balances do need to be done but it has
taken a very very long time for this
family thank you thank you councillor
pemberton
councillor barker
[Music]
i will just uh point you towards the
fact that we have an empty home homes
register
um more importantly
um when
there were syrian refugees
and when there were afghans coming over
and now they're ukrainians
there are other routes than just
applying via
what you've seen from the government and
the county
and i would commend the charities who
help to
place people and sponsor them who do
some of the work
um with refugees particularly regarding
safeguarding so they can be placed with
you in your homes so any of you've got a
spare room or a spare amex or a spare
house
should really be thinking about it and
sadly i'm moving house myself so i
cannot i genuinely can't put them
somewhere for six months otherwise i'd
have had a bunch of people i tried to
get a bunch of syrians too um but that
did prove quite difficult i'll be honest
with you it is a bureaucratic process
and i'm not satisfied with the home
office
and so i i get quite grumpy with the
home office about this that they're just
not pulling their fingers out fast
enough
um i don't know how long the kinder
transport took
i'm too young to remember but i
i'm
embarrassed by the lack of urgency
i have been asked by um
people in my own ward what are we doing
can we have a shipstand for ukraine can
we just get on with it
then i got covered which didn't help
so
we we warwickshire county council i
think has done a really really good job
i think our district council officers
have done a fantastic job
i won't forget the day that david platts
went to get
the cash from the bank
to hand out the 200 quid per ukrainian
who's coming over you know those
practical things have been done
everyone's been running around like mad
things but we really need to put a bit
of a bit of stick around the home office
i wouldn't disagree with you there at
all
thank you are there any other counselors
who'd like to speak
councillor juned
yes i i'd also like to
say uh that thank the district council
officers for their work uh and also like
to thank the communities and the
charities that have been involved
including organizations like welcome
here stratford and similar organizations
we they have done and stepped up the
mark in a way that we know that our
communities uh always do
in these things
i was struck by a couple of uh bits of
research that i did one there was an
article in the local government in um
uh
information um journal that recently you
uh lgiu
recently
which is not known for for taking any
particular political stance it reports
factually
and
they actually said that the government's
initial response to the ukraine refugee
crisis was and in their words pitiful
because across the eu uh people have
ordered about their borders they vote
open to their borders and
the most countries across the eu if
you've got a biometric passport
you don't need a visa if you're a
refugee from ukraine is only in this
country that the visa requirement has
been introduced
one particular story that came up
recently um
struck me because it reflected something
in my own history
and this was about
visa officials demanding that a
six-month-old baby
undergo security scans 800 miles from
the home before she was allowed to fly
to britain
her mother already had a biometric
passport and had been issued a visa
now i remember being in exactly this
situation with a six-month-old baby i
had a had a two-year-old who had his own
passport but i had a six-month-old and a
six-month-old is not allowed to have her
own pas the passport
i went to the um i went to the visa um
the british
embassy in
pakistan in islamabad
to ask for a uh you know for the for my
daughter to be able to come to to
england
the reason we wanted to come to england
at the time was my mother my husband at
the time was very worried about the
political situation particularly the
religious uh situation and he wanted us
out of the country until um until it was
safe
it did not prove to be safe but at least
we were we were out of it um and
a lot of people were actually killed
including
my husband's family several members and
there was a fire that destroyed the
family home but we were out because the
embassy actually said
we will give you put your daughter
six-month-old daughter onto your
passport
they allowed me to leave without having
to go through a visa or for her to have
a biometric passport or anything like
that
they allowed me to leave later on we
went back when it was a bit more secure
but it just shows that that is possible
and for a you know a child you know that
this particular mother
she was allowed to come because she'd
got a visa
her 11 year old child other child was
allowed to come because she had a visa
but the six month old was told that you
have to go and get a biometric security
pass there is something wrong here
now whether or not it's it whether or
not it's um due to inexperience i don't
know whatever the concern
it is wrong it is not it is not
practical um you know some of the things
that have been said
and that the lgiu
article um
praised the public for providing the
bedrooms and and but it also drew
attention to some of the other things
that are going on in the home office
and i would beg you to all of you that
have have influence with the home office
to ask why some of the things are
happening there particularly some of the
um legislation that is going through at
the moment on on
the uk nationality and borders bill
we've got to look at what that
implications are and this is not being
political by any means it is being
asking people to take
a look at what the implications are and
what the impact is on on people i
remember it well myself i did not have
to go through any of the horrendous
situations that people from syria
afghanistan or now ukraine have had to
go through but i do know how easy it is
to get things wrong please put pressure
on and make things work thank you
thank you so we have a proposal and a
second are we all agreed to pass the
motion agreed
thank you so motion two is the local
electricity bill
um so once the motion has been proposed
and seconded we will then uh debate so
please may i invite council adam to
propose this motion
thank you chairman yes i'd like to
propose this motion um
we're at the point uh nationally where
there is a cost of living crisis uh this
is both uh due to inflation and and
causing fuel poverty which is a real
tangible issue that people across the
country
um are having to deal with and that
obviously includes our district
um
we're also dealing with a climate crisis
we've recognized this we've debated this
and and we know that things need to
change to be able to
um to address this again on a national
level but also on a local level
um
and additionally we know we're looking
at a local economy that had to suffer
through a pandemic
we have businesses that need support
that have you know really suffered in
recent years and will need that support
going forwards
the what we've put forward here um is in
support of the government bill um which
has cross-party support including from
um kenworth and southam mp uh jeremy
wright
and effectively allows us in support in
supporting it now and here it uh gives
us the
ability to have that local impact um and
shows a
an aspect of leadership
um in in wanting this support for local
businesses uh for local people and for
our climate
um
effectively it gives a mechanism to fix
the the uk's local supply problem it
allows communities to take ownership of
the
um supply that we know is needed to them
and also encourages renewables in and
around our communities which is um
certainly needed um obviously i've
spoken about this before uh in terms of
where we want these things and i think
having community buy-in um is always
going to be an encouragement um
especially when it comes to sort of
public opinion on these types of things
um
i'm aware that there's a friendly
amendment coming on this i think there
was slight wires crossed in terms of uh
where we are i'm sort of happy about
that we've spoken to
council cargill but regardless um i'm
i'm
really enthusiastic about this topic i
know that many members across this
authority have been
uh from hearing them speaking a number
of times again this is a cross-party uh
proposal and i really look for your
support today so thank you very much
thank you councillor [ __ ]
thank you chair um yes i'm happy to
second this and reserve my right to
speak later if needed thank you
um as council adam suggested there's a
friendly amendment from councillor
cargill so councillor cargill
thank you chad
um oh
i'm looking forward to having a good
debate on this because it is an
important topic
say in principle the motion seems very
supportable so let's get that one in the
in the arena first of all but it's still
worth having a look at this
i should also say that it's all about
scaled
power distribution
the people the the members that actually
said well we've got solar panels on our
roof that's micro and that happens today
and it can happen any any time if you
want to put some solar panels on your
roof no no big deal this is more about
scale because obviously you're looking
to try
and encourage a decent sized more
practical more viable power distribution
system
um
in this district we don't have mountains
so we don't have hydro
thermal you'd have to drill down a
kilometer or more to get any decent heat
so really those aren't viable
biomass
well that doesn't get a great reputation
at the moment
we were discussing that a little bit
earlier on we are actually having to
import biomass in the wood chip from
canada
so it's not a practical thing to do in
that in the grand scheme i think and
large scale as well
so it does look like wherever they got
solar or wind now from our personal
point of view
and
looking around the beautiful countryside
we live in
i don't really want to see wind turbines
now i'm not saying that we you know
that's a dead in the water sort of thing
but i don't think they are viable
so solar just come down
to the most practical
way of generation
there are some issues about this though
um solar does take up a lot of scale a
size
land area
uh back of a pack packet an average
household eight to ten kilowatts demand
uh for scale sake let's assume a hundred
homes that's a thousand kilowatts
uh let's not discuss diversity and all
those factors for the moment please
uh it indicates therefore an area of
around about seven hundred thousand
square meters
for a solar farm and of course we only
get four on average four hours viable
sunshine per day
in in this country we aren't blessed
with that much sunshine
so he's not going to fit in someone's
back garden so we have got issues about
that it's not to say we shouldn't do it
also i have to say that taking that into
account one of the other problems we
will have of course is that
we are talking today about
using more and more land we can't grow
land
we want to plant trees and broadcast
meadows which i too totally support in a
scale as well
but also solar panels do take up an
awful lot of agricultural land
we are now looking for well let's think
about this we are looking for um
power
um
uh security food security
um you know all these sort of things we
need to have balance and i think that
came out with a leader earlier on we do
need to have balance in all these sort
of things
um the final point for me is that the
authority referred to in the bill
uh which against cross party and got an
issue with it
um is the actual electricity and gas
supply authority not us we would only
get involved in this when a scheme is
brought forward to our planning um
planning system as normal so it won't
actually we won't get necessarily
involved there however it's good to say
that we are willing to look at these
schemes if they come forward
like i said it's not without its
problems
and those are the sort of things but in
the bill itself it doesn't mention
anything about well renewables or
anything at all it says sustainable so i
would say let us bring forward
alternate ways of generating power at a
local level not micro but mini to wanted
the description
thank you chad thank you so i just would
like to quickly uh seek a second
to mark councillor cargill's proposal so
councillor parry and now i'd just like
to invite
mr grafton just to clarify on the
amendment please
um
castle cargill i thought that you had
actually
wanted to make
an amendment a friendly amendment
that is correct i have put towards a
plainly amendment to
the uh proposal right as i understand it
therefore if councillors have got the
paper before them
there's a paragraph towards the end of
the um
of the motion it starts
this council further resolves to
and then there are a number of bullet
points
yeah
so the first one
is agreed yes in in your amendment
right to local mps etc the second one is
also agreed right to secretary of state
the third one is slightly amended yes
which would read
inform the local media of the decision
to endorse the bill
and to encourage
interested parties
to consider
appropriate schemes in the district
yes
and the last one i'm not sure about is
that is that one accepted
deleted okay now so casper adam kessler
walcott is that accepted as a friendly
amendment or not
uh yes i've communicated with the the
member and and we agreed that okay thank
you
thank you just like to invite councillor
fragili
to speak
thank you
um
just in response to what uh um council
cardboard just said
i don't see solar panels should take up
any agricultural land or tree plant in
land at all
look at the warehouses we have in
wellsborne
on the outskirts of banbury just to name
two
those are
solar farms waiting to be installed
sadly retro is more expensive and roofs
probably aren't strong enough to take it
but we should be taking the decision
that those roofs should be orientated
for the sun and we should be actually
asking for our solar panels to be going
there
can i just say as well i mean there are
kind of new
my daughter's just looking at putting
solar panels on her house at the moment
as a micro
and
the cost of actually putting batteries
in
alongside the
solar
is not expensive it's not massively
expensive they're not massively
expensive and that pays back
considerably to the householder if they
can afford it
because you don't get the
the tariff
so things are moving but the biggest
movement that we must have is that the
government gives local planning
authorities power to insist that so
appropriate um
uh green energy generation
can be endorsed and planned for within
our planning authority we should have
the power to say what is appropriate for
our district when planning applications
come in
thank you council fielding
thank you chair
um
i'm concerned over this um
what is local electricity
is the aim to install wind turbines
across the countryside
we are in a difficult position due to
the uncertainty created by the conflict
in eastern europe
russia and ukraine are the largest
suppliers of fertilizer and grain
the uk is now in a position where in
order to feed the population we need as
much farmland as available we also need
to produce our own fertilizer and other
materials that require gas
by preventing
the production of gas either from the
north sea or fracking we leave ourselves
very vulnerable
natural gas is one of the main basis of
producing fertilizer and carbonated
drinks and also hydrogen
batteries the cost of importing lithium
being
we would then be held by to the chinese
as they control about 80 percent and
also there is a damage to the congo
where they're reminding it
the government is trying to encourage
expansion of wind farms however a report
from net zero watch who scrutinized
climate policies states that turbines
deliver only an illusion
of
energy security they only work properly
when the wind is blowing
last year we had high pressure the
termites did not work to capacity in
periods of high wind
they must be turned down to prevent the
overloading of the national grid
these companies must be compensated
which is a cost to the exchequer
therefore we need to look for a
combination of gas and wind
the other major alternative
that the government should be
encouraging should be encouraged to push
for is small nuclear reactors like the
ones that are being developed for these
atomic submarines
rolls royce believe that they can
produce the first models by 2024 and go
into production in 2029
eon mass company are also looking to
build their first small nuclear
reactors for 2025 that could be
up and running in wales this would be
the obvious answer to the
electric companies
to feed into the gas
these
systems are modular
and therefore
by putting
small units in
we can they can be expanded they can put
onto brownfield sites they can be buried
underground
but they are renewable and can meet the
needs that are coming forward
thank you thank you councillor rock
thank you chairman um
i just wanted to pick up a few points
that uh councillor cargill made and
first of all
i think he's absolutely right about
making sure we've got the appropriate
technology very surprised
so just wait
um
the
appropriate technology i don't think
we're going to suggest that in stratford
district we're going to have tidal power
i think it's a great omission by the
government by the way because title
power is fantastic in this country as a
whole we've got the best type of power
sites in in the world here and we're
neglecting it in their bill however um
so i think it is a question of
appropriateness however i would disagree
with him he's it's
it's it is neglecting micro
now i spent the last sort of 11 years of
my work in life
in this in this sort of sphere do i need
to declare an interest i'm not doing any
more don't get a pension from it's all
right um the uh
the purpose as i understand it
in this um in this motion
uh and
the promoters of
what would hopefully be a bill is um
is to collect all these things up and
have a way of uh
local electricity have some way of
selling it apart from to these large
uh
commercial organizations that somewhere
getting it forward it's not so much
about the particular technologies that
are involved
for instance
in warwickshire in medieval times there
were
325 water wheels
if we re-enabled all those and you can
get micro turbines now to put into water
wheels
325 water tools it doesn't sound like a
lot but that's a lot
each site could be self-sufficient and
we could be self-sufficient in in those
particular locations i always go and
look there's anybody know the saxon mill
every time i go there look at that water
running through the suction mill and
think there's a lot of energy going
through the through the site there
so
i tend to agree with them water terms if
you look at a a a wind turbine sorry if
you look at a
country so forgetting about the politics
for a minute it's not a sensible thing
to do because is proportional to the
cubicle of speed so um
appropriateness the location but let's
not lose sight of it that what this is
about is the ability
commercially to collect together and
sell your electricity in a better way of
doing it independent of the particular
technology so let's not get hooked up on
that let's also let's get behind it and
support the motion thank you chair
thank you are there any other counselors
who would like to speak
counsel wally hoggins
okay
my dear husband has a reputation for
taking me on the most fantastic trips
and i say that with some irony and a
reasonably memorable one
in there before just before covid was i
was taking on a fun fun trip to drax
power station
and um
it was i've got some fantastic
photographs um
should you wish to see them
mainly not of me facially i have to say
i just deleted those because they would
have just said too much
really
it was mildly more interesting than
going to a wood processing machine on
valentine's day but i i
i'll go beyond that however i'm just
going to come back to mr council cargill
drax power station
uses wood pellets and they do come from
canada because they need them in such
volumes there in order to generate
electricity however we are um in this
country able to access wood pellets from
uh scotland as well so we mustn't i
don't think we should really narrow down
our field to just solar panels or
anything else that you know if we could
say that we wanted the biomass and the
biomass producers can actually pull that
in but i'm very reluctant to say that we
should have biomass boilers that are
being fueled from imports which used to
be from russia ukraine
and from from canada so all of that
eastern bloc has now stopped but we do
have uh dear scotland providing this
for us anyway enough of my holiday
snapped off
thank you councillor parry
thank you chairman i'm delighted to
second councillor cargill's friendly
amendment i just thought it might be
worth advising members
um obviously it's very much a balanced
approach looking at sustainable energy
we currently have
um
10
uh pre and full applications in for
solar farms for the district um the
issue we have of course from my
perspective um i my ward happens to be
in an in an area where
um
it is meant to be suitable landscape
obviously those of you who are up up
towards the north you've got green belts
so you can't have solar panels there
some of you down to the sort of the west
side have got various areas of restraint
so what we have to be very careful about
is making sure and these solar farm
applications i can tell you are pretty
big they're going to be
as they're coming forward they're quite
concentrated in a specific area and not
all of them incorporate
electricity going back to local
communities i think there would be a lot
more support
from neighbours
uh if if the developers actually went to
the extent and put put
invested
in the right infrastructure in order for
huge sways of solar farms which are
coming forward
in light of the climate change emergency
if it was able to go back to the local
community and not all of them do
what i can tell you is i am
certainly advocating that any
application for solar farm subject to
its size and
and obviously the landscape character
etc that at least we you know there is
some benefit to a local community
because we could find ourselves in a
difficult situation
of having to approve or farms going
through the appeal estate to the appeal
process where the local community does
not benefit and that is not the object
of what this motion is about this motion
is about supporting our residents
um and for fighting fuel poverty across
the district so i just want to reassure
you that whilst we've got these 10 large
scale solar farms coming forward i'm
going to try and do my level best to
make sure that our community benefits
and they do not just destruct
fantastic landscape character of
landscape that should be used for food
production thank you
thank you
uh councillor [ __ ]
thank you chair um
yes actually council parry you you
pretty much said what i want to do we
can ensure that actually it's our
community who benefit here it doesn't go
back into the pockets
of uh companies who are already making
large profits off the
um
of the cost of electricity etc
it sounds like to me that there is quite
a lot of agreement in this
again it is not something that hap that
has to happen overnight
this is again something that we can also
be taken in the micro steps as councilor
fragile said
to also large solar solar farms
i'm watching the building going on on
bishop to lane 500 houses not one
not one of them has a solar panel pvc
panel
anything
yet that still
was allowed to go ahead
i'm looking at the ones on chottery
i can say exactly the same thing
but this if us as a council
actually work together to look at
developments coming in looking at new
builds coming in
and work across party to say actually
we we need the pals building we have
five years landing supply but we want to
see these houses being built with solar
panels
and the infrastructure that goes with
these developments
so this is something i do hope
counselors will get behind
because actually it could be a way that
we could lead lead the way as a council
for our residents of stratford
if cancer fudge's daughter is thinking
about it how many others out there are
thinking about it let's be the leaders
here
we can do that and we can have people in
stratford across the entire district
helping each other helping the community
thank you thank you if there are no
other speakers i'd like to invite
council adam to close the debate
thank you very much chairman i'm really
encouraged by the um the comments that
i've heard and i'd say as well that you
know there are real concerns that have
been raised and i share them um and i
think actually what what this comes down
to um which is a very evocative topic
for one thing that we obviously all care
a lot about but what this is is a
mechanism to sort of enable these things
um it's not kind of going into the
nitty-gritty of our where we where are
we going to have this is it going to be
next door to me yeah this is an enabler
to to allow our communities to have that
sense of buy-in um and it and it will be
good for our local economy it will be
good for the climate um
i completely agree um
with councillor parry on the landscape
issues i mean that's something that i'm
i'm
dealing with as well um and i think
you're right the
support
the offer to communities to be able to
buy into this will get that local
support that they kind of need when it's
appropriate but obviously it's also been
noted by
many of the other
all over it can be on new developments
and it doesn't have to just be pv solar
panels
there's new types of technology out
there that i'm sure we don't even know
about which offer
uh solutions to the sort of problems
that we're facing
um
and
again i think one of one of the words
that council cargill said which really
resonates with me is sustainable
sustainability it's not just about
renewable it's not about prescribing a
solution it's finding a sustainable
solution um and that's what kind of this
is for me um
and
yeah i think we kind of all appreciate
that there's a variety of solutions
within that um like i said i'm very
glad to hear the support that i've had
from members very happy with the the
amendment as it as it's gone through um
and so yeah i hope to to get the support
uh
from the chamber thank you very much
thank you so the
motion has been proposed and seconded
and also the addition of the motion so
are we in agreement to pass the motion
agreed thank you
so moving on to item 13 urgent business
please may i invite the leader of the
council to introduce this report which
is the appointment of the section 151
statutory officer
thank you chair
uh
there was a formal process that uh was
gone through
uh to appoint richard burrow as interim
head of finance commencing on the first
of april to allow a handover with the
existing head of finance mike snow
who left yesterday
the appointment of the interim of head
of finance to the statutory role the
section 151 officer requires council
approval
council is therefore requested to
confirm richard burrow as interim
section 151 officer
and we do need a section 151 officer so
the recommendation that richard burrell
interim head of finance be appointed as
interim section 151 officer to the
council for the purposes of section 4 of
the local government and housing act
1989 with effect from monday the 25th of
april i today
so i'm proposing that thank you please
may i seek a second
uh councillor dixon
would anyone like to speak
on this council june ed um just that uh
obviously at an appropriate time we'd
like to know what the permanent position
will be thank you
thank you so that draws the meeting to a
close how sorry is that
is that agreed by everyone okay i headed
myself here agreed wonderful so the next
meeting of council is the agm happening
on the 11th of may at 11 o'clock and
that therefore announced this meeting is
closed so thank you everyone
you